des retrouvailles émouvantes mais
empreint d'amertume
[Musique]
à maradi n'avait pas revu sa mère depuis
une vingtaine d'années le retour du fils
dans sa jordanie natale s'est fait bien
malgré lui amer à dix acquittés amman il
ya 40 ans pour poursuivre son rêve
américain
un rêve qui a tourné au cauchemar en
janvier dernier quand il a été expulsé
des etats-unis ce qui s'est passé est
injuste tout le monde la balle c'est non
quelques semaines plus tard nous le
retrouvons dans l'appartement de sa mère
à amman il raconte son arrestation lors
de rendez-vous de routine avec un agent
de l'immigration et 16
il m'a dit tu es en état d'arrestation
tu vois être emprisonné nous allons
entamer des procédures d'expulsion
je lui ai demandé pourquoi qu'est ce que
j'ai fait mon travail dans les déboires
de monsieur a dit avec l'immigration ne
date pas d'hier
ils ont commencé dans les années 90
quand on lui a refusé le renouvellement
de sa carte verte
les fonctionnaires de l'immigration
l'ont accusée d'un premier mariage
produit lui qu'il a toujours démenti
sa mère a dit avait un permis de travail
et il payait ses impôts fida sa femme
depuis 30 ans une citoyenne américaine
et un maire croit que c'est l'arrivée de
dan trump à la maison blanche qui a
sonné le glas de leur lutte pour
régulariser sa situation aux états unis
fida qui n'avait jamais mis les pieds à
man l'a suivi laissant les quatre filles
du couple derrière aux états unis il se
voit comme des victimes parmi tant
d'autres de la volonté de deurne entre
hommes de sévir en immigration depuis
que le président est au pouvoir
les arrestations relié à l'immigration
ont augmenté de 42%
[Musique]
il s'est présenté comme un sauveur
disant vouloir rebâtir l'amérique mais
en fait iv réclame au nom d'une race en
particulier le contrôle de l'amérique
il se bat pour eux et personne d'autre
c'est le danger de son idéologie
das dender
je crois qu'il était une cible facile
c'est un homme d'affaires il ne se cache
pas il n'est pas venu en sautant par
dessus un mur ils savent où il est
pendant 29 ans il s'est présenté à
chaque rendez vous il était un exemple
facile le laisser partir volontairement
en disant au revoir à tout le monde
n'aurait pas servi leur cause
il voulait en faire un exemple et
l'humilier l'homme d'affaires s'était
bâti une vie à youngstown en ohio
une ville dont l'économie a été durement
éprouvée au cours des dix dernières
années
propriétaires de commerces au détail à
maera d'y est devenu ce que leurs
représentants au congrès t moyenne
décrit comme un pilier de sa communauté
une communauté qui s'est largement
mobilisée pour prévenir son expulsion
il ya tellement de gens dans la même
situation je dirais que nous sommes
plusieurs milliers nous étions des
membres à part entière de notre
communauté
on travaillait on paye nos impôts reste
faible
je suis fier d'avoir embauché au cours
de ma vie aux etats unis
des centaines de personnes qui elles
aussi paient leurs impôts
mais soudainement je suis un criminel
mais pas que notre famille est brisée à
cause de leurs décisions sujet de mon
mari j'ai laissé quatre filles derrière
et une entreprise
j'étais déchiré entre les laisser et
venir ici pour être avec lui
mon gouvernement m'a déçu ce point nommé
madame le couple ne baisse pas les bras
il espère toujours pouvoir être tous
réunis en sol américain une amérique
camair à dire connaît moins aujourd'hui
mais qui le fait toujours rêver et
urbain comment oublier ma famille mon
entreprise ma vie ça fait partie de moi
et soudain on enlève tout ça c'est cruel
pire que ça c'est inhumain et ça ne fait
pas très américain